my name is Matthew Griffith
um and this is a talk about Cogen with
types for humans by humans which for
like code generation when you're trying
to get like a computer to generate code
it's sort of the opposite of what you're
thinking maybe
so this is a talk about specifically
about Elm and Cogen
um which the interesting part may not be
uh what you're expecting
um
so uh who has written a macro here in
any language a decent amount but we're
at strange Loop so that's not like
surprising right like okay uh
was it was it fun
I I I I don't mean it as like macros are
not great right it's more it's just
really interesting the experience of
writing one right so you you have the
sort of this new level of talking about
your code
um which is really fascinating and
probably like mind expanding at the same
time when things go wacky they go real
wacky uh so just in case this maybe is
not for this crowd but like for other
people who are maybe watching it hello
at home
um what is a macro so the way to think
about it and this is maybe like wildly
hand raving is that you have some code
coming in and you have some code coming
out you're actually having a function
that is transforming your code in some
sort of way
so why would you want to do that as
probably the first question uh first one
is you might want to generate some
boilerplate like that's actually kind of
great you can maybe you want to write
some code that is pretty obvious maybe
and you want to write it fast so you can
move fast
you know help serialize and deserialize
stuff that's probably like the thing you
probably might be exposed to
um maybe you want to help with some
external apis whatever that means maybe
it's a foreign function interface maybe
it's like calling an API
um but you want some code and that API
has its own little shape so you would
like to actually generate some code
based on the shape of that code right
interrupt with another another language
or maybe you want to modify the very
language itself you know if you want to
go
lisp thank you for saying it
um
so uh using macros okay they're
convenience right
um save a bunch of time usually pretty
straightforward to use them Magic
uh in a lot of ways sometimes sometimes
a special syntax or maybe not
um inscrutable which is one of my
favorite words because it's sort of just
is also inscrutable
which is not easily investigated
um and it sort of it feels like a portal
to another realm it feels like you're
you're going around writing this normal
code and then you find this macro and
you're like if I add this annotation I
just get free presents okay cool
um writing macros what is that like it's
a basically it's a different abstraction
level you're now working with your code
symbolically as opposed to like kind of
executing things
um
hold on I realized my time thing was not
going uh
so translating translating code to and
from an AST it sort of is like your
bread and butter if you're working on
sort of a macro
um and it's also harder for editor
tooling to follow you just because
you're changing abstraction levels uh
it's just challenging sometimes you can
have great editor experiences but that's
challenging
um does the macro itself use a macro
I don't know uh sometimes the special
syntax and rules and basically it can be
tricky no matter what so there are a lot
of interesting trade-offs
I realize I can actually look at my
slides here as opposed to looking up
there
um
so we're using Elm now Elm is sort of
interesting in that we do not have
macros we
doesn't mean we'll never have macros but
you know who knows
um but we want to generate code to move
fast that's sort of a universal like
desire right the uh what is it the joke
it's like if you don't have macros your
pain is that you don't have macros and
if you do have macros your opinion is
that you have macros
um but maybe we could find a different
set of trade-offs that are more
appropriate to Elm specific uh design
preferences and uh the problems we're
trying to solve right so what is Elm
actually who here has like knows what
Elm is could like pitch it to me
okay
again we're at strange loop it's not
surprising
so it's a statically typed functional
language for making web apps
specifically
um it compiles to JavaScript and we use
a friendly compiler robot that is really
known for really top tier error messages
so uh it's a style programming that I
really love I'm going to take a drink of
water here for a moment
and
uh we use a vendor so vendor crowd
they're over here they're exciting
they're very kind people
um so element vendor type safety is kind
of a very real thing that we have
um just as an overview this is uh maybe
sort of cheating because a lot of uh Elm
like presentations sort of have to
include this slide I feel but we have
600 000 lines of code
that is actually cheating because about
200 000 are code generated so we didn't
we didn't write them but um but they
count it's Elm code
um and uh also the lifetime exceptions
for my time at vendor and when we were
blissfully previously
um zero I might be wrong there might
have been one or two that I missed but
like
um
the issues we tend to work on that are
more challenging on the front end is CSS
business and app logic that's where most
of our brain kind of is dedicated and
ignoring CSS for a moment those are good
problems to solve right
um
and uh this is actually a quote that my
co-worker told me uh basically just last
night we recently rebranded our entire
app
uh it took one developer 5000 lines of
code two days and no brain cells they
were his words uh not mine
uh but really I mean it's you get so
used to that sort of experience where
it's just like okay we're gonna change
some types and you're just gonna follow
some type errors and then you're gonna
like fix it and then you know like look
at some stuff and then like you know get
a review and you're you're kind of good
um
uh so priorities in Elm specifically
clarity
we think about uh types as like types
like if you were to pick like what is
what is so cool about types right and
you might say like type safety but the
more and more I I personally think about
what I get excited about it's I mean
type safety is wonderful like it's it's
it's great but uh types as sort of like
a tool for Thought or like a Clarity of
mind
um and keeping a type system that can
capture that Clarity of mind uh and
enforce some guarantees is uh just it's
that's the magical thing that I want
um and uh you know like if I could get
no runtime errors in other places that's
really cool but I would also miss the
clarity of just being able to sketch out
here's what I want the computer the
shape of things to kind of like move
through
productivity again like you can run
through 5000 lines of code
um and it feels very productive uh in
some cases kind of boring
um which is why Cogen is interesting uh
profound maintaining maintainability via
type safety okay talked about that
refactoring an element is lovely a
strong consideration of design
trade-offs so the type system itself is
not actually that involved and that's
intentional
that's not something that is an accident
or like we're waiting you know until new
stuff is coming out or whatever
um so the things I think about is is
this something we can we actually need
when you we come up with a a use case
right does it need to be in the language
itself
maybe maybe not I don't know
um can it be a library maybe not
maybe it can uh and of course wonderful
error messages just because
um so uh we're not dealing with a super
Advanced type system we're not like kind
of as I mentioned before we're not
dealing with Haskell or rust or even
typescript all of those are more
involved type systems than Elm and
there's nothing wrong with putting more
in type systems just as a concept but
just to give you some context of what
we're actually dealing with right and
and what we're trying to create is craft
a solution for so um
this talk is about not about putting
more things in the type system to do
Cogen it is about taking the existing
types and doing cool things with the
KOJA
um so in some ways Elm is actually ideal
for generating code as a language uh
JavaScript is only created for the
things you use you may have heard of
like uh like dead code elimination as
like something that's like oh that's
nice
um well Elm like that's a secondary step
you have to eliminate the code that you
generated
but in them we did we don't you never
get that far you just have Live code
inclusion the compiler is not going to
create JavaScript for things you don't
use
why would it it's actually makes the
compiler faster
um and again this profound safety uh
we're you're there's no uh escaping the
the safety of the type safety that Elm
has right so uh our compiler robot
friend won't abandon us if we forget an
annotation or if we you know uh slip in
an any somewhere uh it's just not part
of the language it's not something you
have to worry about uh this is great
when you're generating code because you
know okay well at the very least we
still already have those guarantees so
the use cases I'm interested in
specifically for Elm and this is
for me
one is at boilerplate there's a lot of
stuff that you might have to do to set
up an app that um you know it's pretty
standard across basically all apps so
having utilities there are a number of
utilities that are out there already
that do this Elm land Elm pages
and you know an example of this is like
taking a directory structure and using
that to inform how the routes of your
app like the actual URL routes are
structured that's actually a pretty
straightforward and really intuitive way
of thinking about stuff and with some
code gen it's actually not too bad
um graphql we use a lot of graphql at
vendor
um and so this is what I think about all
the time is you know we have a a type
definition for our API the graphql
schema and you know maybe you have a
query could we generate some Elm to
facilitate that interop uh Design
Systems this is actually something that
I'm very excited to explore but there
are a number of places where your source
of Truth could actually come for your
design right maybe it comes from figma
maybe your designers put something there
and you want to generate some code from
there we actually do do that in ad
vendor already you have a little section
with your icons nobody has to export the
icons we just have a script it grabs the
icons puts them in the elm code done
or maybe you want to explore with a
little mini design language of yourself
write Elm code to generate Elm code just
purely
um and editing experiences which I'll
get into a little bit in a little bit uh
so most of these uh like use cases uh
are of the shape external data source to
Elm
so that's slightly different than what
we were talking about before with a
macro right a macro is like we're taking
code and then we're turning it into code
cool
super flexible fascinating now this
though like maybe the things that are
most at our the things we most want as
far as like okay but we we really need
this uh is like external data source of
some sort
um and then we create some Elm code
and so that's basically just what I just
said
um full AST to Elm not as common still
useful uh and also still doable like
when I sort of say these things of like
well maybe we're not going to emphasize
these use cases it's not that we're
eliminating them like uh so full AST to
Elm code you can do that via Elm review
which is a very cool little static
analysis tool there's some kind of
interesting like things that you can
kind of do with that people are
exploring
um be cool to see what happens
um
so can we put rocket boosters on Elm was
kind of like I wake up in the morning
I'm like can we do it uh without
changing the language right we don't
need to make uh profound changes to the
language to do this we can get the
rocket boosters and we can be like Iron
Man both safe and fast
um so first question
not first question I've been talking for
13 minutes already I got to go faster uh
strings are ASDS so
I kind of think or the intention when I
was writing this uh slide was that
people would like look at this and they
would have like strong emotional
reactions one way or the other right
depending on what your background is in
like you'd see like
you know maybe you're like string
templates are actually like they're just
so easy like I mean if I had to write
some code gen uh and I had to do a
little ad hoc coach and stuff I I would
just reach for a string template that
would be that would be what I reach for
but maybe you know so you're like okay
strings easy understandable right asts
okay we're getting like a symbolic
version of of whatever it is we're
trying to represent so that's cool
abstractable you know safe to a certain
degree uh I actually was thinking okay
who here is used in AST to solve a real
problem
okay
okay that's good that's good okay who
here has used a string to solve a real
problem
okay
Fair
um so and just to bring this point home
because this is about ergonomics right
uh you know which do you prefer this is
like obviously just a little bit of
typescript uh we're generating a little
type or here's how we generate the AST
via the typescript compiler not to pick
on typescript the the point
or the ergonomics of asts just in
general
um
and the reason why is because an ASD has
to represent everything it is the entire
syntax tree every possibility is in
there so maybe you have an API right so
this is your little you know Dalmatian
of an API
um and when you have this API there are
going to be some characteristics and
you're going to have to spend some time
to figure out these characteristics
because it's going to be some things are
going to have larger blockers they're
going to have like either there's more
information that someone needs to know
to use it
or maybe it's just like there's just
like this weird kind of challenging
thing it's not not like dangerous but
just like a pain like oh I have to fill
in this thing and fill in this thing
okay and maybe there are other parts of
your API which are kind of explicitly
like dangerous meaning like someone
could break their code like um like not
be type safe it was like okay if you
mess with this great uh just be careful
and the user may see and there's a
it's decent contrast so they may see
like the little money sign like it's
like I want I want that thing that thing
that's good that's really great so like
yes
and then they're like but I have to do
all of that and it's like well that's
not great
that really that really sucks
um so when you're in this kind of
situation uh there are a number of
things you can do
um possibly the most well-known of the
tricks here at least in maybe the
functional static typed realm is sort of
making uh
uh error or what is it I don't want to
say impossible States impossible because
that's Richard's thing but like you want
to make uh problematic States just not
representable and like they cannot be
constructed right so the first thing is
just remove it from from the API in some
sort of way they can't say the word that
blows everything up great can it be an
internal thing
um maybe you can do the work for them
so you can take something that was
explicitly dangerous before you can say
like you know we're just going to
calculate this for you so it's both
something you don't have to think about
and it's safer
uh and you can also de-emphasize tricky
apis so basically what that means is
taking them putting them in a well like
you know labeled place in some sort of
way maybe you're taking an advanced API
and saying this is the advanced version
it is more powerful explicitly but uh
you know it's also a little bit more
dangerous so you need to be aware but at
least there's an intention there and the
last thing is aligning to your user
intention that good apis tend to do this
really really well where they know
exactly what the user is trying to do at
every step and what power they're trying
to get at every step so
um and this is what happens you get a
smiley face
you have lower cognitive load and more
space for fun
so I'm going to try to get through this
pretty quick uh the uh thing I think
about is like how frequent are different
tasks there are some tasks that
everybody's going to be doing when
they're using your project there are
some tasks that only a few people are
going to be using there's also a
difficulty related to each one of these
tasks now the tricky thing with you
working on your project is that your
perception is on these on these edge
cases almost by definition the common
case is something you probably had
handled to a certain degree pretty early
in the project so you start to move to
these edge cases and the Temptation is
you look at this and you see that one
dot that is like really tall and you're
like I just want just want that thing to
go down and so you pull that down and
you're like everything is better right
except the thing that you weren't
looking at kind of went up in difficulty
and even if it's a few percentage points
it kind of doesn't matter if ninety
percent of your people need to use it so
maybe you made the one thing that ten
percent of the people need to do uh like
a lot better but then you're 80 90
people kind of suffered and that's just
not great so uh did we make the easy
things hard like uh it's just something
to think about Simplicity or
learnability is not a property of the
language it's something we have to
constantly strive for people sort of say
Elm is a simple easy to learn language
and I think there are parts of it that
are just incredibly well designed and
there is some like foundational
Simplicity there that I really love but
as a tool maker it's also very obvious
to me that any given tool made an Elm is
not necessarily going to have those same
properties unless you're actively
thinking about this stuff so the goal
easier than a string template safer than
an AST
let's do some coaching
so elmcogen is a library in a CLI right
so it's El library and a little tool you
can use what does this actually look
like
um well that is a little function call
right we have to be comfortable with the
int is a function call and five is the
argument right no parens we can just
call by a little space there and we
generate a five wonderful obvious very
cool
um there's a little bit of missing code
here that I'm going to be eliminating
from future slides just so that uh you
know things don't get too weird but
basically there's a little function that
calls tostring on what Elm inch returns
which is an expression and then we get
that actual string so like this is a
very concrete we're not dealing with too
many weird things here and Elm it
did my think oh there we go um Elm
itself uh the name or the module it's
not anything built into the language I
just was kind of sneaking I was like
you're generating Elm code I would like
to name the namespace elm but it's not
something special
um and in case you wanted like this is
like the typescript translation read it
very quick and I'm gonna go
um
so okay so what if we want to generate a
file well we have to we have a file we
have a module name and basically we can
have a list of declarations so in this
case we have my int 5
turns into a five that's cool okay so we
got the module declaration at the top
that's great
um something interesting kind of
happened here we got the my ant five but
we also got a type signature uh where
the heck did that come from
um well uh Elm Cogen and sort of
aligning to the like user's preference
of you know what would you want is I
would just want type signatures when you
can when I can get them just for free
can I get them for free I don't want to
write them like writing them would be
more work and I don't want to do it
um so uh
with that uh in mind Elm Cogen will try
to figure out the types from the local
AST so the little tiny piece that you've
created it's actually going to kind of
go through do a little type inference
thing which was actually really
interesting to write because I'd never
written one of those before
um and if it can it will generate a type
signature if it fails no problem just no
type signature you can manually override
if you want Elm compiler Will Never
Never Let You Break Stuff if you forget
a type signature or something does not
come out that's fine like Elm Cogen will
uh maybe give you a warning in case you
actually want to ensure that your
generated code always had type
signatures so if you want to have that
level of you know uh whatever you're
fine but if but you're still just going
to have like the generated code and
you're gonna be able to run it and as
long as it actually compiles you're good
um okay here's just a list again there's
just this theme of we are taking
Primitives we're sort of wrapping them
uh so we say like oh here's this list
and then we just call Elm list and then
we get a list
um fantastic
so
what about generating functions well uh
here's an example of a function we're
going to add two things together
wonderful what is this excuse me what
does this actually look like
well the first try would be something
like this so
there's an immediate problem we have
here so we have you know we have a
function we have a function
we have a function called function oh my
god
um and it takes a list of arguments just
like names of them and then we have a
little expression down here
elm.op.plus and we now we have to
reference those names again now
immediately I'm it's like okay well
but that's not like that much of a
burden to our users right they just have
to match the strings it's fine
but we could just do it for him so uh
instead we can have this kind of
construction so what we can do you uh
declare kind of the function uh airity
that you want so in this case like a
function two takes two arguments provide
the two names it's going to you can pass
in a little like Anonymous function a
little Lambda and it's going to give you
two values with kind of those names
baked in so that's cool so now you
actually have these values you can't get
the names wrong if you're using long as
you don't use like the elm Val manually
right
um but we can either what about calling
generated functions right because I mean
if you're going to declare it you're
probably going to want to use it well we
can actually have another layer of power
so you can actually have the first
construction as something that's in the
library and something like I just want
to generate a function don't bug me in
this case we can actually have another
place in the API to declare these
functions
and instead of just creating the
Declaration we create actually a record
and that record includes both the
Declaration
and a way to call it and the way to call
it bakes in how many arguments it takes
right so all of a sudden you have some
protection not just around like
generating the function but when you
want to call it you now have some level
of it's not really a guarantee but you
have some level of assurance that you're
going to call something with the right
number of arguments which is kind of
challenging and Cogen when things get
really weird
um so what does this look like
declaration declaration when you call it
turns into the call
safety
head massage
okay calling external functions um so
this is calling external functions let's
say we don't we're not generating a
function we actually want to call
something from a library we have a cool
Library we want to use and we want to
call it so the way that you would do
this normally in an AST is that you'd
call something called apply right where
you take one value in this case that's
that whole thing and you would apply a
certain number of arguments now it's a
list so you kind of see this and maybe
you're I know I look at this and I like
get a little like nervous I'm just like
okay
well let's let's go let's go with it
that's fine
um and then uh it generates some code
okay this is cool and we think about
well we got another free thing we got
another present here which is that
um from the AST uh why can't we just
always calculate what our Imports would
be right why would you be dealing with
Imports in your AST just in general
where it's like well
I know it knows exactly what things to
import so just just give me that and
let's like not worry about it
um so that's cool that's great but
there's a problem I mean first
celebration yay
um but uh does html actually exist as a
module uh I hope I spelled it right uh
that's fine uh it does text actually
exist in HTML again
uh there's no annotation that's fine we
have our type inference thing like right
so like I mean it would be like you know
maybe our types of your just sort of
goes away because it needs to be
calculable from our little AST so I
would like a type signature there but
I'm kind of busy so and then okay well
but how many arguments does a Chanel
text take
um well I mean I know it's one it's fine
uh and I well it takes a string too like
okay so so there are are a number of
things that are problematic with calling
like external like functions right and
the key part about this is that the vast
majority of code gen that was
interesting to us at vendor was about
calling external functions so it's like
okay great you can make this little cool
little AST that's kind of local and you
kind of get to this point where it's
just like it's great it's great except
when you try to do something that you
really want to do and then you're like
oh oh no
um so and there's the oh no I forgot to
put that in there
um so let's flip it around we have this
what would we like to write to generate
that
maybe just that
Maybe
maybe that would be cool how are we
going to do that let's take a little
detour we're going to take a detour
at Salem packages so
um Elm has its own package management
system
um in there we have uh like basically
generated docs for everything which is
pretty cool and in those docs we have
like all these like kind of like type
signatures you cannot publish a package
to the elm package repository without it
basically type checking and actually
having explicit type signatures or
whatever so we have a very strong idea
of what all these values are that's
actually just really cool just in
general and there's another module
called uh project metadata utils from
the core Elm uh you know people Evan I
suppose um and the interesting part
about this is that it allows you to take
your docs Json and actually get
structured information out of it so it's
a Json thing that comes back but then we
actually get like a kind of a breakdown
what the like types are now what's crazy
about that is this is like we're sort of
at The Meta programming level
we're dealing with our types as values
right and this like I'm just this makes
me like so excited that this system for
Elm like that's it like that's the whole
thing
um there might be like one there's one
or two things that actually aren't
explicitly in there but that's fine
they're not that big of a deal
um so with that in mind we have a bag of
recipes html text we have string to HTML
right this is how you generate HTML in
in Elm
we have this Json value like again just
to represent we have these types but
they're as concrete values it's easy I
remember thinking about like if I would
have heard that maybe 10 years ago I'd
be like but that still doesn't make
sense to me trying to be like it's
literally like you have a list and and
the strings in the list describe sort of
the function that you're trying to do
it's like these are things that are just
immediately you're used to working with
um so we could actually absolutely
generate a function that mirrors an API
in Elm but instead of basically calling
those functions it's actually generating
an expression to call that function
so what does that actually look like
um looks like this it looks like the
apply we actually talked about this is
the exact same thing we were writing
before the only thing that's different
is we basically just hit it behind a
function and we're taking in a string
and we're returning this expression that
calls this string this construct
actually allows you to be safe around
calling that value and then we can make
another little version of this which is
you know call text which instead of
taking the actual string it will take an
expression so it's like okay so that's a
little bit more abstract still useful
depending on what you're trying to do
what does this look like well you just
say like elmcogen install any package it
actually I literally verified this for
every package in the elm ecosystem so
anything you can bind anything that's
published you can get bindings for
essentially so you may see something
like this you'd get these are bindings
this is like this is creating a div with
some text in it like this is if you
write Elm this looks very very familiar
uh to what you're writing when you're
writing your view code and basically
that's what it generates so we've
created a convenience gradient
so we start out with concrete values
it's the most concrete and also the most
convenient the thing that we're saying
is like I have values now and I would
like to generate some Elm separately we
have the next level of convenience right
which is a little bit more abstract I
want to create an expression so who
knows what that expression is it might
be like you know maybe you're composing
a string together like doing some
operations or whatever maybe it's an
argument coming in from one of those
functions we were trying to create
earlier
so slightly more abstract and less
convenient again this is represented
like literally the convenience by like
nesting it within this little call
record right
um and it's basically saying I will have
values at runtime there's kind of this
time portal thing going on and if you
want to use the elm apply original
version of this thing you can do that
it's the most abstract maybe you want to
change airity for some interesting
reason uh which is can be totally valid
uh and it's least convenient and this is
sort of the hold my beer approach
um
match the level of abstraction to your
users needs is sort of the insight there
you can basically say like we're going
to allow you to write what looks like
pretty much normal code and like maybe
if there'll be a few tiny caveats or
whatever and you can start there kind of
get your like get your C legs for it and
then you can move to more abstract as
you need to
so fun internal note Elm Cogen has
bindings to itself so that it's easier
to generate bindings for you so within
elmcogen there is
gen.elm.ince5 which generates l.nt5
which would generate five
uh so like do you do you feel it like at
a certain point in thinking about these
things it's just like wait wait like do
I have a brain or like do I just have
like a symbolic representation of a
brain like uh it's uh it's
simultaneously very fun but also
fascinating
um so what did we get we got generated
Imports are done for you
um free type signatures most of the time
generated code comes out formatted uh
generator uh code the thing that's
generating the code is just Elm there's
no special rules
um generated code is just Elm easy to
inspect the code is meant to be
inspected uh as opposed to sort of a
macro where you're like well I need to
install this tool to sort of expand it
and like
uh there's no hole in your tooling
because of an escape hatch uh JavaScript
is only generated for you because of elm
we just got that for free we didn't have
to do anything uh generated variables
automatically avoid shadowing and
collision this is something uh we didn't
really look into but
um it will actually detect when there's
going to be a collision and sort of Auto
hash it but only when there's a
collision which is kind of fun
um parentheses handled for you uh
generate code for generating code that
calls existing libraries similar to
writing code normally airity protection
type protection sometimes again we like
we had a function that took a string and
we could call the generator with a
string if we wanted to now if we wanted
to go more abstract less safe so we get
to choose our level of abstraction you
start concrete move to the level of
abstraction you need uh more abstract
less safety
uh refactoring experience and clears the
mind
so but really elmcogen is a tool Maker's
tool
what does it enable right I mean tools
are great I love making tools at the
same time what sort of experiences like
does this actually translate into
benefits is kind of the question so
um we created ad vendor and we've been
using this for a year or longer I don't
remember exactly how long about there
um called mgql and it's a pretty
straightforward you write graphql you
get out
um so Elm gql the type system for
graphql in case you're curious is
actually pretty similar to Elm there are
a few places where it's kind of
irritating but they're similar enough
that there's no read need for them to to
get like super super fancy in a lot of
ways so what does this look like I mean
you can probably imagine this pipeline
it's like the uh I think the insight to
this is just that it's so simple you
could you know people be like yo what's
lmgql you'd be like uh you know you
write gql you get Elm
great
um so gql you check it right so we're
actually taking the schema that we have
and we're writing a type Checker again
um and we're checking to make sure that
it's semantically valid or like
everything valid um and if it is great
we get an Elm file and we look at it and
then we profit
nice or
we get a nice error message again we
love the elm error messages we want
little like typos we want to tell us
exactly what was the option space what
did how did we screw up just make it
very friendly and very approachable
um so the benefits incredibly fast to
write graphql queries can't call the API
incorrectly compilation error if the API
changes correct data returned in
beautiful Elm types something we did not
have to worry about decoders and
encoders for free this is something that
sort of people they come to Elm they're
like uh what the heck is a decoder why
do I have to write it before I just had
data and there's some very good reasons
why you'd want to have a decoder
um
but also there's some very good reasons
to not want to write them you know just
because you got other stuff to do
um
and in this case in the library there's
also Elm Define gql fragments that can
give more control over the exact type
that's actually being returned in case
you're like well in this specific
situation uh I I do want something a
little different than what you're
generating
um
so the generated code is the interface
it's meant to be looked at it has
automatic generated examples so this
lgql I was working with a co-worker and
we were talking about you know we're
trying to create like basically figure
out this API and we're generating a
decent amount of code and my co-worker
was saying well but how like how do I
use this code you know I mean we went
through all these design things but I
need to literally write uh like uh
basically to construct like the inputs
right to actually maybe do some
interesting filtering to send up you
construct that in Elm when you're
sending it up and so I'm like okay well
we can generate some examples and that
turned out to be really really
interesting
um when we were generating the examples
we found uh it was actually a way to
sort of uh review the feel of our API at
scale we could actually generate Elm
code for our graphql API look at it and
being like well you know optional inputs
for gql which for reasons I'm not going
to get into her are sort of a little bit
of a pain in Elm or they just don't
they've made different decisions but now
we can see whatever Choice we've made to
actually deal with that situation we can
now just click around and see what that
looks like via the example that's
generated
um we even use the generated examples to
fuzz our back end meaning we we're doing
an upgrade that was a little we wanted
to be we had we wanted some level of
understanding that our entire API wasn't
uh it was a very foundational kind of
upgrade we were changing libraries right
so I'm like well we have all these
examples should we just like throw them
at the server and see what exceptions
are thrown and we did that and if
through some exceptions and some places
that we didn't go to very often so we
caught that that was pretty cool but it
got me thinking uh could we generate
examples for all Elm code
uh just because why not
um and is that even useful was sort of
the other question
um so
I'm going to try to get through this
super quick uh example generation from
Elm types what does that look like it
looks like type Tetris the algorithm a
humble button this is this humble list
of buttons it takes a string and it
shows the string right so if we want to
create an example for this well we need
to create is basically a bucket of
things that are creatable things that we
could actually just shove in there these
are like Primitives we could drop in so
string and Boolean wonderful we need
another bucket which is viewable stuff
so viewable stuff is anything we can
render this the screen once we can do
that again we have these values we have
the little recipe bag to actually create
this stuff so we can actually just find
out like oh it takes a string returns an
HTML wonderful I can render that
um okay in it creates a button and then
we have view which creates uh takes a
button returns HTML cool well that means
we can actually look at init we find in
it we're like okay I can create a string
and once I create a string I can create
a button so we put a button in our
creatable little thing that we're really
like tracking and and then once we can
create a button we look through and like
what else haven't we created well we
haven't done this like oh this creates
HTML great we can view it
so we take this a little bit further I'm
going to skip that one just because uh
running kind of slow so the last bit
here the thing you initially do is you
put everything as Primitives in there so
you this this part takes a string this
part takes a Boolean cool
you can take that one way further where
you can basically just say like well
instead of that I'm going to give you a
reference to our model which is going to
have that string and I know for a fact
this takes one string and one Boolean
like I'm going to actually
use this piece to create a UI input to
drive it uh so with that in mind here's
the elm dev demo let me try to do this
super quick
um
nice
okay so on the left here is a button
there's code it doesn't really matter
what the code is it's basically the
button stuff we were just looking at
with maybe some stuff but we also have
oh
did I not
kick off
no I did
come on now
sorry give me one moment
there we go so um we did it we did the
demo um so on our left we have our UI
button uh actual source code it's
actually paying attention to what we're
looking at on the right is a con uh a
calculated example output of what we
actually want so basically we can say
like here like uh you know we can
actually write like whatever code and
it's actually updating the example sort
of in real time
um we actually get the output we can
actually see oh that's interesting like
our button is actually constrained a
little bit too much so we can actually
remove that constraint
and it immediately reloads and expands
sort of as you expect now it's like okay
well maybe I'm writing and I'm expanding
this API uh well okay I'm going to add a
with enabled right to be enable or
disable the button we can save that
immediately the controls update where we
can actually update uh enabled or
disabled
we can say like oh do we want like
secondary and small it's like well yeah
we definitely do
um
again all these things are sort of just
live uh and it's like okay well that's
cool but that's for like visual stuff
right I mean it means like we're
basically creating storybook.js like in
our thing and that's useful it's
incredibly useful and we get it for free
which is so cool but what about you know
any given thing so here's a mini
markdown parser that I wrote and again
we had our buckets of viewable things
and creatable things those are just
functions it like if you can provide a
function that takes uh like any given
type and is able to render it in some
sort of cool way
um then you could make a viewer and
maybe that just lives in a folder in
your like project and you're like well
for this type I would like to view it
like this and this type I would like to
view it like this like basically
immediately like extensible
in your code base
um so with that in mind we can actually
like pick you know uh with this let's
look at our header thing we can actually
check out
um that like you know here's
you know my header
um and it's like okay so that's cool and
like we noticed that like actually for
our parser it's actually going to stop
parsing after that so that's an
interesting characteristic about our
parser it's just parsing that first line
we don't necessarily care right here in
this demo but you might care when you're
trying to figure out what your parser is
doing and what how would you do that
before before you may actually stitch
together an entire app to basically
visualize something like this
um and then if you want to you can go to
uh like the full parser which is
basically the header like this only
parses headers and lines right so uh we
can be like you know here's like this
it's a header three and then like here's
you know uh
my line uh and another one
um and there's no reason like this is
basically just a the output here is a
generic one there's a special output uh
that basically you can just take any
type and just just show me what that
type looks like
um
so yeah let me see if I can get back to
my slides
so visibility values I kind of use the
complement of static types we sort of
think of these things as sort of
separate like oh we got like you know
lisp over here and they got the rebel
and we got like the static types over
here it's like let's just look please
let's have both uh is my personal
feeling
um and hopefully soon this editor
concept I really want to it's not ready
yet but there's a lot of cool stuff to
explore uh I got the elm.dev domain name
which I feel so happy about
um uh Elm Cogen is out now uh the number
of projects that I want to base on top
of it which is graph vendor lmgql a
design system generator and some editor
experiences are going to be coming out
hopefully pretty soon
and uh that's my talk I'm Matthew
Griffith and uh yeah vendors hiring come
talk to us